I want to talk to you about a hunger for God.
Not a hunger for food that's controlled by a hormone in your stomach called ghrelin.
And ghrelin may not have heard of it, but there are two ends or hormones in your stomach that control your digestion, insulin, and ghrelin.
Ghrelin is really important.
It does five things for it.
It signals the brain to increase your appetite.
You wouldn't be hungry if you didn't have ghrelin.
It stimulates your pituitary gland to release growth hormones.
Third, it stimulates your digestive system to move food from your stomach through your intestinal tract.
Fourth, it helps your body control insulin release.
And fifth, it plays a role in cardiovascular health.
I want to talk to you about having a hunger for God because in the same way that ghrelin does things for our body physiologically, a hunger for God will do things for you spiritually.
It's important that you and I have a hunger for the things of God, because it does take us deeper into our walk with the Lord.
Proverbs 27 and verse 7, this video text for tonight, a person who is full refuses honey.
But even bitter food tastes sweet to the hungry.
The NIV puts it this way, he who is full loath's honey.
It's interesting that word loaves means tramples.
So what you have is when a person is full, even something that's good, even something that's good for them, even something that would be universally thought of as good is all of the sudden trampled under the foot is criticized, is not wanted, is not desired.
And I wanna suggest to you that when people lose their spiritual hunger for God, the good things in their life are unappreciated.
The good things God wants to do are unappreciated.
And I wanna give you just quickly three principles on spiritual hunger.
First of all, a lack of spiritual hunger will keep us from receiving.
In Proverbs chapter 27 and verse seven, he who is full loath's honey.
The spiritual fullness that the writer Proverbs is talking about, he's using honey and something that tastes bitter.
He's using all of that as a metaphor for our spiritual life.
And he isn't talking about what he's talking about here is not a fullness of God, but full of other things.
I mean, it's being full of opinions.
There are some people who aren't hungry for God because they're so full of their own opinions.
There are some people who aren't hungry for God because they're so full of their own preferences.
There are some people who are not full of God because they're full of worldliness.
They're more worried about their status, they're more worried about their income, they're more worried about their own self-accomplishment or sensuality or greed.
Some people are too full of other things
for God to fill them.
My question to you is, are you hungry for God tonight?
How does it happen that a person could actually find themselves in a place where the presence of God is so real and not be hungry for it?
Be looking at their watch to wonder how much longer are we going to do this?
He's saying, well, you know, I hope they do this.
I hope they do that.
You see, they're full of their own thoughts, their own ideas, their own opinions.
One of the ways that happens is through familiarity, what happens, we get so used to it, we no longer are in awe of it.
One of the things I pray for myself is, God, give me a breathless awe of what you're doing in this place that I might always be amazed of the hand of God that rests on these people and on this church and its ministry.
When what is extraordinary becomes ordinary in our sight, it's a sign that something's wrong with our spiritual hunger.
Another is a consumer mindset.
I mean, what's in it for me where church becomes about us and it's what we want, what we like, what we need, how we feel.
If that's what drives you when you come here, rather than I've come into this place and God is going to come down on the praise of his people, he will be enthroned, he will be here and I'm here to worship him.
When we have any other agenda, primarily than that, it's because we're not hungry.
hidden sin will always cripple a hunger for God.
Pride will cripple a hunger for God.
It's pride that says, I'm fine.
It's pride that says, I know it all.
It's pride that says there's nothing new that I need to learn.
There's nothing new I need to experience.
I've experienced it all.
I've seen it all.
And if it's something I haven't seen, I don't want it.
That's pride.
The problem with being full is that instead of entering into a move of God,
we begin to evaluate the move of God.
We begin actually to love it.
It's too long.
It's too loud.
It's too emotional.
It's not my style.
I'm not comfortable.
I like so-and-so's preaching better.
We sing too many new songs.
When those things start coming out, you gotta see that as a warning and say, whoops, something's wrong here.
And the problem is with what's happening on the platform, it's what's happening in the heart.
Because suddenly it's become about you instead of about what God is doing.
When you're full, you don't come to the table to eat.
You come to the table to evaluate the menu.
So ask yourself,
Do I come to the services asking what's in it for me or do I come to the services asking God, what do you want to do in me?
Listen, can I be honest with you?
I'm not here to analyze the move of God.
I'm here to be wrecked by a move of God.
I mean, that's the whole thing.
You say, well, give me a chapter in verse.
When Isaiah saw the Lord and he was high and lifted up and his train filled the temple and we just sang about that, what did he say?
What was me?
I'm undone.
I'm a wreck!
If God comes into place and we don't eventually come to that moment where we're so overwhelmed by His power and His presence, and at the same time so hungry for more, something is wrong.
I'm here to be rearranged by a move of God.
I'm here to say whatever you want in my life, God.
I'm here to say, God, it doesn't matter what I think, what matters is what you want to do.
It's your house, it's your place, and we've come to worship you.
You see, when a person doesn't have a spiritual hunger, what they do have is the spirit of control.
Rather than yielding to the Lord, they want to control things.
And usually it veers toward their comfort, their preference, those kinds of things.
Listen, hunger is so important because without it, you can't receive.
Number two, hunger changes your taste.
Look at this, that's so interesting.
A person who is full refuses honey.
But even bitter food.
How many like bitter food?
Anybody?
You're like, I love bitter food.
If you're hungry, you will love it.
If you haven't eaten for seven days, bitter food's gonna be your best friend.
You're like, man, I've never had anything so good in all my life.
That's what it's saying, but even bitter food tastes sweet to the hungry.
You see, hunger changes what you and I are willing to embrace.
A hungry person can receive.
They can receive correction that stings but heals.
They can receive conviction that's uncomfortable but cleanses.
They can receive confrontation that's a little bit uncomfortable but causes them to grow.
Because a hungry person is not looking for God to cater to them, they want God to transform them.
You will know if you're hungry by what you want God to do for you.
If you want God to cater to you, you're not hungry.
You're selfish.
This is a hard word.
I mean, if that's all you came for is what you could get, it's all about you.
And nothing we would ever do will in the long-term please you.
But to the hungry person every day is a feast.
I can't remember where that is in the Bible, but it's in the Bible.
To the person who's hungry every day is a feast.
Everything is when you're hungry, it's like, wow, I can't believe I get to be a part of this.
When you're hungry, you just wanna see God do more in you so he can do more to you so that you can glorify him.
You're just saying, God, whatever you want me to do, however you wanna use me, it's not about what I want to do, it's about what you want me to do.
And I'm just here at your disposal, God, I'm hungry for you.
Bitter means challenging, but even bitter food tastes sweet to the hungry.
So bitter could be challenging, stretching, sanctifying, humbling.
Because when God's working in a place, let me just assure you of this.
And I don't care where you've come from.
When God is working in a place, He will do things to offend your mind so that you can see your heart.
He'll do things you don't understand.
He'll do things you can't explain.
Because he wants to find out if, because if you gotta have an explanation for everything, you gotta understand everything, then you're God.
When you're in the presence of God, you come to the end of yourself and you come to the beginning of him and he is a mysterious, awesome God.
who you and I cannot completely understand.
His ways, his works are too wonderful because his ways are higher than our ways.
And so when you and I come into the place where God is moving, we have to be careful that we aren't offended by what God does.
It's in Matthew chapter 11,
John had heard in prison about the works of Jesus Christ, Matthew chapter two, or 11 verse two, excuse me, he sent two of his disciples and said to him, are you one coming or do we look for another?
Jesus answered and said to them, go and tell John the things which you hear and see.
The blind see, the lame walk, the lepers are cleansed, the deaf hear, the dead are raised up and the poor have the gospel preached to them.
Then Jesus says this, and blessed is he,
who is not offended because of me.
Think of how many people were offended by Jesus' ministry.
So easy to get offended by what we don't understand.
Why this person got healed, this person didn't, or especially hard if you're the person who didn't get healed.
Why this happened or why that happened?
I'm not talking about unbiblical chaos
But I am telling you that in a move of God, there's a lot of things that happen that leave people with questions.
On the day of Pentecost, they were amazed and perplexed and confused.
The Bible uses all those words in from verse six to 12 in Acts chapter two.
If any of us think we can come into the presence of God and understand everything that's happening in the presence of God, we're being foolish and spiritually unwise.
And what I'm saying is the posture, the appropriate posture is to say, God, I'm just so hungry for you that I want everything you wanna do in my life.
And I may not understand it even as you do it.
I know this a few years back, there was this season where every day I wept, I wept so much that my voice, I lost my voice.
People were saying you better go through an ear nose throat doctor because you're gonna wreck your voice.
And they were like, what's happening?
And I said, it's from weeping.
That's what it's wrong.
I didn't understand it.
At one point, I thought, maybe I'm going crazy.
I mean, you're kind of like, this is, this is, I just would begin to weep.
And then we'd go for hours in the presence of the Lord.
I look back on it now.
I have a much better understanding now than I had then.
But God was doing a work in me that he wanted to do.
There wasn't what I would have preferred, but was what I needed nonetheless.
I'm just simply saying, I look back on it now and it'll be something I'll never forget for the rest of my life.
And it's not the benchmark for God working in my life.
It's just another experience of God working in my life.
And I stand here tonight and I say, God, whatever you want to do, whatever it is,
I'm in, I'm on.
I'm hungry for more of you.
I want more of you.
Ask yourself, have you found yourself offended by things that make you uncomfortable?
Listen, I'm not talking
What we've experienced and done is very much within the confines of Scripture.
Let's be clear on that.
But it is outside the bounds of most people's tradition.
And for many people outside their comfort zone.
And that's okay.
Ask yourself, have you found yourself offended because others around you are more passionate about God than you are?
If it offends you,
that people are passionately worshiping God, that problem isn't theirs, it's yours.
You should be delighted that people are so passionate and hungry for him that they've lost theirself in him.
That's a glorious thing.
It is why there's a freedom in our worship today that we hadn't had for 30 years.
And I will always take that.
Ask yourself, have you found yourself offended because your church preferences and traditions have become more important than wanting all that God has.
So, you know, like, well, I don't think it should be done that to this, this, this, your opinion, your preferences.
I'm just simply saying, if you find yourself offended by what God is doing, invariably it's because there isn't a hunger for God.
That's what this scripture is.
We go back to Proverbs 27 and verse seven.
A person whose full refuses honey, he loads honey.
He doesn't want anything to do with honey, doesn't need honey.
Jesus said this, and Luke, I think it's chapter five and verse 38 or 37, and no one having drunk the old wine wants the new.
The old they say is good enough.
You have to be careful when you're hungry, you want the new wine.
So Jesus is safe.
He was new wine.
I'm just simply saying, how committed to pursuing God are you and how willing are you to say God, have your way in my life, whatever that looks like and whatever that means.
Hunger is third intensified by pursuit.
Musicians you can come.
A person who is full, refuses honey, but even bitter food tastes sweet to the hungry.
to the one who's pursuing it, Psalm 34 verse eight says, taste and seed that the Lord is good.
In other words, spiritual hunger isn't a personality trait.
You can't look at people who obviously are spiritually hungry and say, well, that's just how they roll.
No, it's not a personality trait, it's a pursuit.
It's a decision that they made to say
I'm gonna go after God.
Now I'm just gonna tell you, for most of my ministry, I live the fairly reserved life.
I'm very committed to the Lord in one sense, but very reserved in the other.
And the problem is, when reservation that can quickly become about your own dignity and your own image becomes more important than what God wants to do in your life, then you will miss things God would have done in your life
that would have benefited you.
And so I'm simply saying, the better thing is to say, I don't ever want to be in a place where I'm turning up my nose at what's good.
Honey's good.
Taste and see the Lord is good.
He's good.
And I don't ever want to be in a place where I'm saying, well, you know, that may be
But this is where I want to be because then that means I've lost my hunger.
When I've lost my spiritual hunger, then spiritual death has begun to set in.
Hungry people show up early because they're eager to receive and want to prepare themselves to receive.
And listen, I'm not putting a guilt chip on people with families and you're getting off work or you're getting off work and you can barely get here and you're rushing.
So you get in the last, you know, at the end or not at the end, but at the end.
The service story started.
Listen, we don't take attendance.
We're not sitting there with a stopwatch.
We're not looking at those things.
But I'm just saying, if you can, if you're hungry, you get here.
Because you want to prepare your heart.
You want to say, you know what?
We want to be ready for what the Lord wants to do.
Hungry people lean into worship.
The arms aren't crossed, they're raised in the air.
And I realize some of you are totally new to this.
And I get the journey aspect of that.
So I'm not trying to be unkind.
I'm just simply saying that the Bible talks repeatedly and we have messages on it you could listen to on the value of raising your hands and what it means to do that and how that will do something.
The Lord will do something through that in your life that will bring victory and blessing to your life.
Hungry people come to the altar because
Pride isn't driving them, need is, and the desire for God is.
Hungry people, and this is something hungry people respond quickly because they aren't negotiating with God, they're pursuing God.
So if God's speaking, my heart has heard you say, the psalmist said, come seek me, your heart will I seek?
He doesn't say, well, you know, I've got, I'm keen, you remember that God, and I've got an appointment here, an appointment here, and I've got an army, I've got a manage, and Joel Abs is driving me crazy.
No, David says, my heart has heard you say, come see me.
Here I come!
Without, that's the mark of a hungry person.
Here's what he says.
One thing I've desired, this is what I'll seek, that I might dwell in the house of the Lord, all the days of my life.
that I might behold the beauty of the Lord.
All of these things, there's this desire to instantaneously move into the presence of God when God is calling to say, I'm in, I'm on, I want it, I'm hungry.
So hunger doesn't just admire the menu, it orders off the menu.
It says, hey,
I'm gonna take you up on that taste and see that the Lord is good.
I'll have one of those, one of those, one of those, one of those, and anything else you wanna give me, I'm gonna eat.
It's that hunger for God.
Let me just wrap this up three steps to a hungry heart.
Number one, admit your need.
For some of you, there are degrees of hunger.
We all understand that physically.
Sometimes like you're starved, and other times you're like kind of hungry.
For some tonight, the admission would be, I'm not as hungry as I used to be or I should be.
And I don't want to stay that way.
You know, a hungry heart is a person.
A hungry heart a person is a person who's full on for God, who's wholeheartedly seeking God.
If you're not hungry, then what happens is
you really risk being in the place of being half-hearted or lukewarm toward the things of God.
Hungry people are on fire.
They just want anything and everything God has.
So if you're not there, and you say, you know, there were days when I was hungrier than I am now to say, God, I am not as hungry as I used to be, and you're gonna have to change that in me.
But I'm saying, here I am,
You tell me what to do.
I'll do it.
Number two, return to the table.
Don't wait until you feel it.
Too many feelings won't lead you into depth spiritually.
You have to just say, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna worship.
I'm gonna be at the altar.
I'm gonna have my devotional time.
And then to all of us, Lord, increase my capacity to desire you.
for you.